[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour nous un moment extrêmement
important c'est important pour brest
mais c'est aussi et surtout important
pour la planète comment on trouve des
solutions face ou plutôt comment on met
en application des solutions parce que
celles ci existent face aux grands
problèmes que que connaissent les océans
et par conséquent les pays côtiers et
les villes côtières
[Musique]
étant que ça bouge parce que la mer va
pas bien il faut la réparer ce tissu qui
est vital pour nous parce que c'est un
tissu
régénératif qui est porteur de vie de
santé comment ensemble de manière
coordonnée et solidaire responsable
durable on va faire vivre cette partie
du monde qui n'est rien rien que 70% de
la surface du globe voilà voilà l'enjeu
[Musique]
on est déjà dans un sacré bazar enfin
c'est un peu comme la coop 21 ans sait
pas trop où on va avec toutes ces
décisions politiques mais je pense que
les politiques ne prennent pas forcément
en compte tout ce qu'il faudrait et je
pense que la solution elle viendra aussi
des citoyens des mesures doivent être
prises après la mine la mise en
application est sûre plus compliqué
difficile et lente mais il faut se
rencontrer après entre les paroles des
actes il ya souvent un gap qui est
difficile à combler
[Musique]
malheureusement je pense qu'il faut pas
en attendre des miracles non plus ce
qu'on voit dans ce genre de grandes
réunions en général c'est c'est plutôt
un éléphant qui accouche d'une souris
nous ce qu'on attend surtout c'est des
annonces concrètes sur des mesures
efficaces pour lutter contre la surpêche
parce que la surpêche qu'elles soient
illégales qu'elles soient légales et de
la première menaces qui pèsent sur la
survie de l'océan qu'on ne peut pas
parler de changement climatique ou de
lutte contre le changement climatique
sans parler de préservation de la vie
marine comme on sait que la surpêche et
la première menace qui pèse sur la vie
marine
voilà cqfd
[Musique]
deux possibilités la primaire est
optimiste la cnds sert résistent
ils interféraient cet activiste
l'intérieur
[Musique]